si le vuelve a salir a las calles en una
jornada en la que se conmemoran dos años
del estallido social del 18 de octubre
la fecha que cambió la historia de chile
para siempre las manifestaciones se han
sucedido a lo largo de la capital y de
todo el país desde temprano en la mañana
la asociación de estudiantes secundarios
se manifestaba a cerca del costanera
docente en el centro comercial más
importante del país y recordaba que
fueron ellos al saltarse los torniquetes
del metro los que iniciaron un poco esta
revuelta social conmemora un helecho
volviéndose a saltar torniquetes de otra
estación de metro son diversas las más
infestaciones que han sucedido a lo
largo del país muchas de ellas se han
concentrado en torno al edificio de
donde se encuentra la convención
constituyente es en este lugar en el
entorno de la convención constituyendo
este honda también se escribe una nueva
página de la historia de chile y es que
la convención constituyente salida de
todo este proceso de revuelta social
inicia hoy mismo la escritura de una
nueva carta que va
de destinada a reemplazar la heredada
por la dictadura de augusto pinochet en
1980 hablamos con algunos de los
convencionales constitución
constitucionales que nos explicaron la
importancia de este momento histórico ya
un día
para conmemorar cuánto chile como
decimos nosotros de expertos en este
momento veo que se están moviendo son
pocos la gente que se está manifestando
espero que sigan saliendo a manifestarse
pero pacíficamente y que crean en el
trabajo que se está haciendo en la
convención porque en el trabajo que se
está haciendo acá dentro es un trabajo
arduo donde si queremos cambio donde si
vamos a tratar de lograr ese cambio en
esa constitución se espera que miles de
personas acudan también en el día de hoy
para conmemorar esta fecha que cambio
chile para siempre y donde todavía están
los reclamos de las diversas demandas
sociales entre ellas pensión educación
salud que todavía no se atienden también
en un momento en que dos años después
chile está más cerca de la impunidad que
de la verdad y la justicia entra en
cuanto a las graves violaciones a los
derechos humanos ocurridas en el
contexto del estallido social entre
ellas a las más de 500
450 personas que sufrieron trauma ocular